right now in the US labor market we're
looking at two numbers the first is a
hundred and six that's the number of
consecutive months the US labor market
has added jobs the most ever recorded
the second is 3.2 percent that's about
how much wages have grown each month in
2019 from a year earlier in a healthy
economy annual wage growth is usually
around three point five percent so
despite record-breaking jobs growth we
just aren't growing as fast as expected
and many economists aren't sure we're
going to see much of a pickup from here
[Music]
let's take a closer look at the numbers
in theory low unemployment should
encourage employers to raise wages since
they're competing to retain workers and
also hire from a shrinking pool of
employees but that's not what's
happening employee paying benefits as a
percentage of gross domestic income fell
to fifty two point seven percent in last
year's third quarter marking the fourth
straight quarterly decline compare that
to when it was as high as fifty nine
percent in 1970 and 57 percent in 2001
in other words if workers commanded as
much domestic income as they did in 2001
they'd have nearly eight hundred billion
dollars more in their pockets or 50 $100
per employed American economists have
identified some forces contributing to
this one of the factors squeezing
Americans out of higher wages is
automation rapid advancements in
robotics technology and artificial
intelligence are expected to displace
millions of jobs in coming decades as
routine tasks from driving trucks to
checking out at the grocery store become
automated the share of tasks at risk for
food preparation workers for example is
91 percent
economists say workers and industries
where automation is taking over jobs
have less power to bargain for higher
wages analysts at the Brookings
Institution say less educated workers
are especially likely to have their jobs
displaced by automation so it ends up
being these workers who have a harder
time demanding higher wages another
contributing factor just lower wage
growth is the decrease in unions union
membership in 2018 is about half of what
it was in 1983 that means the power to
bargain for higher wages has decreased
and employment contracts have become
less favorable for workers for example
employment contracts have become
increasingly riddled with non-compete
agreements Evenstar an economist at the
University of Maryland estimates that
roughly one in seven workers making
$40,000 or less
signed non-competes his research found
that states that enforce the clauses see
lower wages across the course of workers
careers than states that don't
that's because non-competes can
discourage workers and low-paying jobs
from looking elsewhere since they might
not be able to move from one company to
another even interns are increasingly
being hit by non-competes
which can prevent them from moving on
from temporary jobs to full-time gigs
that would pay them more
another factor contributing to lower
wage growth is the growing gig economy
but the growth of the freelance and gig
economy there's more uncertainty for
workers this gives them less leverage
for negotiation and fewer rights than
full time employees would receive in
some cases gig economy workers have been
able to push for bigger paychecks New
York passed laws in 2018 that required
lyft and uber to pay drivers a minimum
of 17 dollars and 22 cents an hour but
that's not been the case everywhere
globalization is another reason why wage
growth has been sluggish because of
increased competition from overseas
where wages are sometimes lower American
companies are often reluctant to raise
wages for US workers US companies have
been outsourcing jobs to places like
Mexico China and India where they can
produce goods for much cheaper
that means US workers have been left
with less bargaining power when it comes
to their own wages the idea being if
your boss can find a worker overseas
who's willing to take a much smaller
paycheck why would they be willing to
pay you more
for example Mexican vehicle assembly
workers made less than $8 an hour on
average in 2017
in comparison the median wage for North
American workers in the auto
manufacturing industry was 15 to 16
dollars an hour so how do we predict
wage growth will change in the future is
this slower growth expected to continue
it's tough to say how this will play out
but members of Congress are pushing for
legislation to increase the minimum wage
and recently the house did pass the
raise the wage Act although people say
it's probably unlikely to make it
through the Senate
[Music]